secrets britanniques
c'était comme un fou du roi dire d'être
impertinent d'être audacieux comme le
fou du roi de remettre en question
l'ordre établi est peut-être la
meilleure manière d'être fou du roi
c'est d'être pleinement soi même en
dehors de toutes les conventions
maintenant une mauvaise nouvelle c'est
que ça suffit pas il ya un autre nous
conditions essentielles pour être
créatif et pour réussir dans sa
créativité sa gestion du temps et je
vais vous montrer à quel point le secret
pour être créatif d'être un fou
discipliné il ya quinze ans j'ai quitté
mon métier j'étais rédacteur en chef
depuis un magazine pour enfants et j'ai
pourtant quittés parce que j'avais un
rêve je voulais devenir auteur
illustrateur des lits pour enfants
j'étais tellement exactement longtemps
vous attendez moment là que j'ai décidé
de prendre une année sabbatique et une
année pour simplement prendre le temps
de m'investir totalement dans la
création de quelque chose de personnel
de sortie et se faisait dans les tripes
dans le ventre dont petits coeurs et
d'apprendre à bien le faire avec
l'espoir qu'au terme cette année j'aurai
une matière suffisant pour intéresser
des éditeurs et je me rappelle très bien
le premier jour c'était en septembre
2000 j'étais dans mon bureau
tout excité et j'avais tellement la tête
pleine envie de faire c'est de choses
dans cette année là que j'ai pris une
grande feuille de papier et j'ai fait ce
que vous faites peut-être dans vos cours
un my maps une carte mentale avec toutes
les idées de ce que vous voulez faire
alors j'ai écrit inventer des histoires
mettre en image des épisodes de ce que
j'avais vécu comme enfants apprendre la
technique de la couleur bien utilisé
apprendre la technique d'écriture
rencontrer des auteurs illustrateurs que
j'admire prend du temps avec ma fille de
5 ans que vu mon boulot précédent devait
finalement peu plus de temps pour pour
être avec elle et une fois la feuille
plein j'en ai pris une autre que de
diviser en fait colonnes comme les sept
jours de la semaine et j'ai pris tous
les éléments de ma carte mentale et les
ennemis dans une semaine dans un sommeil
alors j'ai commencé en décidant que tous
les matins parce que le matin ces
moments je suis plus concentré
vous allez faire des projets de livres
pour enfants et que tous les midis parce
que je sais que après le déjeuner
généralement mon sens est en train de
digérer mon sandwich et aidera il n'y a
pas grand chose aux athées donc je vais
m'asseoir et pendant une heure lire pour
apprendre des choses me former et puis
que tous les mardis midi
jal est invité à déjeuner une personne
que j'admire et dont je voulais
apprendre des choses et que tous les
mercredis après midi parce que dans mon
pays en belgique ce le veau ou les
enfants en congé et bien j'allais passer
un bon temps de créativité que ma fille
est que tous les jeudis soirs je les
faire une toile à l'acrylique
pendant un an je me suis tenu
strictement à cet horaire et j'ai passé
une année extraordinaire au tome
laquelle je suis allé avec mon portfolio
chez un éditeur qui très poliment à
refuser les projets que vous lui tendez
mais sur le pas de la porte malheur
c'est un défi ce que tu voudrais pas
écrire un livre sur la créativité
j'ai dit oui en neuf mois il était conçu
écrit illustré et trois mois plus tard
il était publié si j'ai une fleur
m'envoyer c'est d'avoir appris à
m'organiser
c'est ce qui m'a permis de
de dabou tirs 7 à cette situation cette
capacité à s'organiser
j'ai continué à y réfléchir pendant
toutes les années qui ont suivi et où je
suis devenu consultant en créativité et
dans le dernier bouquin que j'ai écrit
je me suis intéressé au génie comment
foulée génie de ce monde pour penser
comment leur viennent leurs idées
créatives les constater plusieurs choses
que d'abord ils ont sinon une méthode
une manière de penser iv particulière
denard de vassy il prenait des notes il
aurait rempli 14 mille pages de notes de
questions de dessins etc
einstein il pensait en images disait
d'ailleurs imaginer sans plus important
que la connaissance
walt disney son talent et sa méthode
c'était de faire travailler une équipe
autour de lui mais il n'est pas juste
une méthode on constate en constatant en
vendant biographie tard en élisant des
interviews de créateurs contemporains
j'ai remarqué qu'ils aient également une
discipline de fer
trois exemples vous connaissez tous
peut-être stephen king qui peut
certainement une production immense et
bien stephen king il fait il écrit dix
pages par jour
je suis parfois des pompages le matin ça
pour être en forme la leaf et c'est
comme des pompages et fait 10 passes par
jour
tomi ungerer qui est un immense auteur
illustrateur d'origine alsacienne de
livres pour enfants lui il laissait le
bohème par excellence il est issu comme
c'est l'évidence le vent il vit dans une
ferme en irlande et il s'astreint à
minimum 8 heures à sa table de dessin
par jour de dessin pur et il dit la
discipline c'est la clé rené goscinny
immense créateur de mutu duc astérix le
petit nicolas il avait un horaire régler
comme comme une boîte à musique tous les
matins à 9 heures pile il se mettait
devant sa machine a écrit les scénarios
de bandes dessinées à midi il déjeune
avec son épouse dans son appartement
parisien
et puis il se rendait au journal pilote
dont il était le rédacteur en chef
donc je suis persuadé et je le vois par
l'expérience que la meilleure amie du
créatif c'est leur loge et son pire
ennemi c'est l'absence de délai un ami
proche voulais écrire un livre
nos spécialistes de la finance et après
avoir demandé conseil
les cris une table des matières un
premier chapitre il va voir un éditeur
parisien qui dessine un contrat qui dit
très bien monsieur j'ai beaucoup de
projets qu'en pensez vous être prêt et
il dit écoutez neuf mois ça vous va
et les termes dudit très bien il
commence à écrire le temps passe et il
prend plus de temps que prévu
on prend du retard et deux mois avant le
dîner il téléphone à l'éditeur indique
août et je suis pas prêt est ce que
pauline petite rallonge les dijonnais
raconter ce que vous voulez quand vous
serez prêt vous m'appelez travail un an
passe deux ans passent après deux ans et
le chapitre 3 9 et 10 et abandonne il
abandonne son projet donc on a besoin de
délai on a besoin de délai et à défaut
de recevoir un des l'extérieur il faut
s'en donner de l'intérieur mais parfois
le délai il peut faire peur il peut même
être source d angoisse
depuis plus de 12 ans je suis également
dessinateur de presse je travaille pour
un grand quotidien belge la libre
belgique et dans ce journal voici trois
exemples de dessin que j'ai réalisé ici
c'était avant l'élection du nouveau pape
va françois joua chaises musicales
ceci c'était un article sur la difficile
conciliation entre les outils les hutu
les tutsi dans la région des grands lacs
en afrique
est ce si c'était un plaidoyer pour la
fermeture des usines nucléaires
c'est super auteurs des dessins de
presse j'adore et je suis fier de ses
dessins je trouve qu'ils ont bien rempli
leur mission
mais ce que vous assurer qu'au début
quand j'ai commencé à faire ses
activités c'était la panique
j'en lis le téléphone ou difelice veut
bien faire un dessin pour demain tu es
autres ford est forcément c'était ma
vocation
et puis je reçois l'article est
instantanément la panique la panique
celle là c'est le noeud dans l'estomac
qu'est-ce que je bien pouvoir trouver
comme idée au départ de ce fichu article
au demeurant sur un sujet qui ne
m'intéresse pas plus que ça
le pire c'est quand un journaliste m'a
téléphoné jeudi en disant de bien faire
un téléphone à téléphone un art un
dessin pour mercredi prochain
alors je stressais vendredi samedi
dimanche lundi mardi
parfois je passais des heures le week
end dans ma feuille blanche à essayer de
bongo la bonne idée au lieu de m'occuper
de mes enfants mon jardin ma femme alors
que je gagne 75 euros par des sens j'ai
donc décidé très rapidement d'arrêter
cette idiotie et de remplacer la panique
pour la stratégie et voilà comment
depuis plus de dix ans je travaille avec
la montre première demi-heure et je me
met très vite au travail quand je le
peux qu'en vertu de l'article
je me donne trente minutes montre en
main pour pondre cinq dessins variés qui
pourraient convenir pour l'article mais
je m'interdis de me mettre la pression
en disant que de retrouver la bonne idée
et puis je laisse reposer je fais une
pause je vais courir m'occuper des
enfants cuisine et dormir faire un autre
travail et je reviens dessus quelques
temps après et là je sais pas si vous
avez des remarques et quand vous avez
pris du recul vous voyez les choses
autrement
l'idée que je trouvais intéressante ne
l'est pas tellement une idée que j'avais
sous-estimé peut se révéler tout à fait
opportune parfois rien ne conviens mais
en mélangeant des idées on trouve une
troisième est parfois une sixième idée
m'est venue en courant dans mon bain etc
toujours est il que là aussi 30 minutes
montre en main je fais le dessin
définitif et je l'envoie ou vont être
plus jamais de stress et jamais la
prophétie négatif qui nourrissait mais
modestement de réaliser jamais ils m'ont
téléphoné en me disant philippe on veut
pas continuer de collaborer avec toi je
crois donc on peut tous gérer notre
créativité en gérant le temps de la
créativité en mesurant le temps entre la
divergence qui ait le temps de
l'ouverture la plus la plus totale de de
la pensée organique et spontanée de
l'émergence des idées spécialité du
cerveau droit et le temps de la
convergence qui est le temps on va
sélectionner développer les idées les
structures et qui est la spécialité de
notre cerveau gauche et cette dichotomie
là on peut également le manifester dans
l'espace quelqu'un m'a fait remarquer il
ya quelques mois quelque chose que je
fais depuis des années c'est que j'ai
deux tables dans mon bureau d'une grande
table que j'essaie de garder la plus
vite possible avec en périphérie un bloc
de feuilles a3 et a4 dépôt ticket avec
des feutres de couleur et c'est là que
je fais mes cartes mentales des croquis
des notes tous azimuts mais surtout dans
des ordres et puis j'ai un autre bureau
ou sur un ordinateur mon scanner des
choses comme ça et c'est là que je
structure des idées que je les mets en
ordre j'ai visité à paris une école qui
ressemble un petit peu à la vôtre
s'appelle epitech qui est une école
d'informatique et
de mes connaissances françoise brauner
avait pour mission de concevoir les
locaux d'un espace où les étudiants
d'epitech vont rencontrer des
entreprises pour mener des projets
communs et bien c'est intéressant que
les espaces sont véritablement distincts
il ya un espace d'exploration à l'entrée
de ses locaux vous voyez cette salle où
il ya bibliothèque dvd ordinateurs
restent a de quoi se nourrir du monde
extérieur que ce soit dans la discipline
exactes sur laquelle sur le sujet dont
on s'occupe bien sûr sur d'autres sujets
et puis à une salle de brainstorming
harcelé un peu particulière là une forme
entre le cercle et l'hexagone comme ça
là des tables et des chaises mobile on
peut écrire dessiner sur les murs c'est
la salle ont produit des idées tous
azimuts et puis il ya la salle de
sélection de développement des idées
lorelei à des ordinateurs forcément
c'est une école d'informatique et des
outils du matériel pour faire des
prototypes
enfin et à la salle de communication
dans la se marrant il ya un bel écran
des canapés un petit bar et c'est là
qu'on invite les clients que toutes les
diplomaties requises et le sens du
commerce ont valu vendre notre idée donc
si vous aussi nous avons envie d'être
créatif n'attendez pas d'avoir un grand
projet moi ce que vous propose en
conclusion ces deux disciplines et votre
créativité et de la mettre à l'agenda
petit truc très simple vous appliquez
presque tout de suite après mon
intervention se la posent allez parler
un inconnu et je crois que la salle
regorge de rencontres potentiel
intéressante
à vous de voir vers qui vous dirai quand
vous rentrerez chez vous tout à l'heure
prenez un autre chemin et perdez-vous
volontairement vous découvrirez ainsi
peut-être un coin nouveau près de chez
vous que vous ignoriez fait la même
chose qu'on vous fait de votre footing
je le fais ma femme au téléphone parfois
presque à la police parce que je mets
deux heures d'une demi heure mais c'est
comme ça que j'ai découvert des nouveaux
quoi enfin si vous allez faire vos
courses demain ou après demain
quand vous serez au magasin h un aliment
que vous ne connaissez pas encore quitte
à changer de marque de spaghettis on l'a
dit précédemment il faut pouvoir
oser le changement et le provoquer en sa
vie pour ne pas être victime de la
routine je crois que le créatif ou celui
qui veut l'être peut faire sienne cette
phrase de eleanor roosevelt et en faire
sa philosophie fait chaque jour quelque
chose qui vous fait peur c'est
exactement ce que vient de faire devant
vous et je vous remercie